بعد نحو عامل من حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
عكس لقاء الرئيس الامريكي بقاده تسع دول
اعضاء في النيتو من اوروبا الشرقيه
والوسطى تشكل ما يسمى مجموعه بوخرست وجود
قلق لدى هذه الدول على مستقبل امن وسلامه
اراضها حيث تخللت الاجتماع دعوات لتعزيز
دفاعات هذه الدول لتكون قويه عند الحاجه
اليها وتعزيز الوجود الامريكي شرقي اوروبا
علما بان واشنطن نشرت اكثر من 20 الفا من
قواتها في اوروبا منذ بدء الحرب
اليوم هو بحضور الرئيس بايدن نؤكد ماهيه
الالتزام من الاداره الامريكيه من اجل
تحقيق الامن للجانب الشرقي من حلف شمال
الاطلسي ونتطلع الى تعزيز الحضور الامريكي
في المنطقه والاستعداد الاستراتيجي من اجل
البحر الاسود الرئيس بايدن الرد برساله
طمانه اكد خلالها التزام بلاده بامن كل
شبر من دول النيتو
التزام الولايات المتحده بالنيتو واضح
تماما الماده الخامسه هي التزام مقدس
تعهدت به الولايات المتحده سندافع عن كل
شبر من النيتو هذه لحظه مهمه اتطلع فيها
الى المناقشات والخطوات التاليه التي يمكن
ان نتخذها معا للحفاظ على تحالفنا قويا
ولردع العدوان بشكل اكبر وما هو على المحك
بمعنى الكلمه ليس اوكرانيا فقط انها
الحريه من جانبه اكد الامين العام للحلف
عدم الرئيس بوتين للسلم مع اوكرانيا وقال
انه لا يمكن السماح لروسيا بالاستمرار
بتهديد امن اوروبا
لا نعلم متى ستنتهي الحرب لكن علينا ضمان
ان لا يعيد التاريخ نفسه بعد ذلك راينا
اسلوب العدوان الروسي في جورجيا وفي شبه
جزيره القرم ودومباس واستمراره في اجتياح
اوكرانيا لا يمكننا ان نسمح لروسيا
بمواصله تهديد الامن الاوروبي وعلينا
انهاء هذه الدوامه من العنف الروسي حلفاء
النيتو اليوم اكثر وحده من اي وقت مضى
وسندافع عن كل شبر فيه
وكان الرئيس بايدن قد القى خطابا من وعسو
مع قرب حلول ذكرى الاولى لحرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا اكد فيه دعم واشنطن راسخ لكل من
اوكرانيا واوروبا واستبق رحلته الى وارسو
بزياره الى كييف احيطت بالكثير من السريه
اكد خلالها دعم بلاده الذي لا يتزعزع
لجهود اوكرانيا في الدفاع عن اراضيها
نت جوله الرئيس بايدن اكثر من رساله وفي
اكثر من اتجاه لعل اهمها التاكيد على
تصميم الاداره الامريكيه على تعزيز الدفاع
المشترك للجناح الشرقي للنيتو وطمانه
اوكرانيا وجيرانها هي لاي اطماع توسعيه
مفترضه لموسكو في المرحله المقبله الجزيره
وارسو